picked up by james johnson
johnson kicks it out to thomas shot
clock winding down thomas across the
lane
foul line jumpers good contact that's
the adjustments even the great james
harden had to make he was struggling
early on in the season and thomas nice
little step in the second half
cam thomas finds a spot jumper got it
three-point game
[Applause]
thomas jump shot it's good tie game
the knicks have led this entire game
largest lead by 28 but brooklyn with a
chance to take the lead
thomas jump shot
first lead of the night for the nets now
instead of run
a pick and roll
thomas long three-pointer puts it in pam
thomas from way downtown oh what a shot
from the rookie
and brooklyn goes up by six with 6.8
remaining
what a fourth quarter for cam thomas
[Applause]
and the pain for the nick fans here at
madison square garden 16 points for
thomas in the final period
young fella got it going they flatten it
out 1-4
no pick-and-roll just you and me cam oh
cam flat out getting it done putting on
a clinic in the fourth quarter putting
his team on his back and making every
right play mama there goes that man
again he was two for 11.